could be worse not that for me it's all
about perspective it's what you make of
it
All Things Considered I'm actually kind
of comfortable right now thank God for
shock I can be the kind of prisoner I
want to be still alive thank you
right mm-hmm just two injured buddies
yes mm-hmm
having a friendly convo while we're
waiting to get tortured again and you
know there's a kind of a positive in
having no options yeah because you know
we're not gonna try to escape because we
don't we fail yes I'll tell you nothing
don't miss the arm really first of all
Lefty okay so this thing pretty much got
in the way keep it buddy do fools your
suffering has just wow that is a perfect
summation of the human condition
once you've embraced that you can do
anything bingo you mean you love your
work and that kind of a positive
attitude quite frankly is contagious it
is will see how positive you're feeling
after I cover your body in gasoline and
set you on fire
you know what it's amazing that you
would say that because I was just
thinking it's getting all chilly in here
huh thanks so much man what a dramatic
and fascinating man I think we owe him
big-time as to why really I mean all
this time away from my computer my phone
my work it's just I feel unplug yes yes
circle of life
Nozick Wayne yeah you know I can't
really feel anything anyway so you help
yourself buddy
Oh what it out there this is what I'm
gonna use to cut up finally that's a
great saw I'm a home-improvement guy and
I know my sauce and I gotta tell you if
you're cutting off legs that is the way
to go that's the one that is definitely
the one good on you
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa whoa somebody needs a day
off we of all people should know how
hard he works
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you